[Musique]
la séance plénière autour des
orientations budgétaires s'est déroulée
dans l'hémicycle du palais de la source
mercredi 24 novembre le président du
département Cyril Melchior à dévoiler le
plan de mandature de la collectivité sur
la période 2021 2028 voté à l'unanimité
par les conseillers départementaux
sur la lutte contre la pauvreté et la
précarité sur le territoire de la
réunion de 38 poissons des familles
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
et nous voulons travailler à faire en
sorte que ça peut t'arrêter recul ne
voulant lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales
fait en sorte que l'éducation populaire
se développe encore plus parce que ce
sont des gens qui ont été un peu oublié
ces dernières années et bien nous
voulons retravailler avec les
partenaires sociaux pour une fois la
misère recul sur la Réunion plus de
l'éducation les collèges travailler
contre la vulnérabilité des enfants plus
de structure d'accueil pour les
personnes les personnes porteuses de
handicap voilà les ambitions pour départ
le départ de la première déclinaison de
se plaint de mandature passera par la
mise en place d'actions de lutte contre
la pauvreté et l'inclusion sociale vient
un accompagnement renforcé des personnes
en situation d'exclusion
et les autres se feront dans l'année 22
samedi 5h parce qu'on fasse pour quand
même des personnes
Le Petit Bleu comment les appelle qui
sont en souffrance
la collectivité va également investir
des 2022 dans le domaine de l'éducation
populaire en renforçant son soutien dans
l'accompagnement des plus précaires
notamment avec la caravane d'Accès au
Droit
sur l'île de la Réunion qui vont aller
dans les quartiers retirer dans les
écarts ou dans les quartiers
particulièrement difficile pour
favoriser l'accès au droit parce que les
personnes en situation de précarité
difficultés mais souvent ne savent pas
qu'elles ont des droits sociaux où ils
ont du mal à faire les démarches pour
accès à ses droits accéder à ses droits
d'où la caravane qui va aller vers avec
des travailleurs sociaux des
professionnels qui font la démarche
d'information d'explication qui seront
le premier maillon vers les services
spécialisés du département ou même de la
CAF ou même de la CGSS pour favoriser
l'accès à ses droits sociaux
du département se lève
l'action sociale
[Musique]